he tells me all the time he's like my
dad didn't love me and then I hug him
and then he pulls out his dick and
that's usually that's our friendship
[Music]
welcome back to another highly
enthusiastic episode of the careful boys
we have with us Mr nimish Patel today
[Applause]
hey we were talking about something
before we started rolling I thought it'd
be cool to expand on it how do we feel
about serial killer series or
documentaries being a little too
glorifying for the killer I I'm not
looking forward to Jeffrey Dahmer
costumes
this Halloween and it's already starting
to bother me because white people always
look kind of strange in their goofy ass
decisions
he's not even full dude oh [ __ ] that's
not even really authentic no he's the
guy that Jeffrey picks up at the club
yeah
I'm down I do the little dance
would you would you give credit to like
creative costumes from Jeffrey Dahmer's
series like that what like blood
everywhere I think being Dahmer himself
is a little like that's easy if you can
like a human meat sandwich with you and
start giving it to people and that would
be a costume and and you're holding a
vintage Budweiser can oh yeah that's
cool I'd be like you really went for it
that's the best part of Dahmer is like
what a raging alcohol he was like it's
the best part he's always [ __ ] you
know drinking pvrs the whole [ __ ]
show with no beer belly do you think
that was a brand deal I think so yeah
for sure it feels a little bit like it
when he says it the first time he goes
like two pbr's like it says a little too
clear yeah you have to kill somebody
he's like PBR the most delicious beer
and then stabs oh damn you know you just
see the PA turning the cans so that the
logo's facing camera continuity you know
what's a good costume I think if you're
a fridge and you open it and you're the
head in the fridge that's a good costume
the freezer right that's too much
commitment to a [ __ ] serial rapist
murderer yeah and then that way you
could be any serial murderer it doesn't
have to be necessary or you're just the
first victim and then the entire time
you walk around all night dancing you're
just like I'm not gay though yeah
that might not be a costume
that might just be a real situation do
you think there's like another side to
having these uh what do you they're not
documentaries right they're series but
it's like there's like another side
that's like kind of like oh let's show
some awareness to like how crazy people
actually were you know what it is it's a
road map okay for everybody else out
there blueprint it's a blueprint it's
[ __ ] it's a reward in a way it is a
reward for sure because when you watch
it you're like murdering all these
people is not that hard like what's the
last time early 90s yeah pick up a bunch
of loners I was like I could I could do
that I think I think I can get like five
off yeah just like mentally prepares the
next psychopath right they're just like
oh this is when he messed up maybe if I
did it like this it'd be clean yeah
maybe don't have the heads in the fridge
you know
yeah like he wasn't even trying
they don't have hundreds
hundreds it seems so easy to kill people
back in the 90s he just had a giant uh
what's called that yeah just acid like
how did you just get that in the 90s
right like what scares me is that like
when you look at his method and you look
at the entire thing it's Plug and Play
you just gotta find the most
unrepresented not cared about minority
currently and that's the one that you
can get the most kills off before you
get caught so go ahead which what is it
what's the most underrepresented
minority
you got to go to really specific
communities yeah like that's really you
got to like do some research what's too
small probably that Community there's
not enough of those if I'm a Serial
murderer and I'm thinking like I can
only murder Native American people who
are trans like
that's going to be hard but how many how
many people are in the fighter comedian
Community you know what I mean what the
the comedians that are also fighters oh
that's a good Community to Target oh
Brendan Schaub he's the only guy
no way I'm gonna kill that guy Ronnie
Chang yeah
Ronnie we coming for you man tell Ronnie
do you guys know Ronnie I don't know is
he a fighter oh yeah he's been training
Jiu Jitsu for a while now
um but yeah Ronnie we come in man
demographics we're down you would see
that or Native American trainers
I think it'll be harder to murder a
fighter versus just like a random person
because spiders know how to fight yes
sure 100 probably not dude probably not
probably not because you know because
you know what you wouldn't expect it
though because if he doesn't shake hands
with me first and then bump and then sit
on a butt and I don't know what the [ __ ]
I'm gonna do because is it biting in the
ring it's like a different mindset than
fighting out in the street like you're
not ready for it you're not prepared
would you have gone away if you were the
first victim Jeffrey Dahmer how would
you have got out of that as soon as he
was like hey uh you want to come back to
my place and take some photos I'll be
like I'm good sir let's say you're
already there he's like I wanted to take
some martial arts photos and you're
[ __ ] an idiot he's not gonna get you
some head shots I'm in the bathroom
getting pumped up
yeah I'm in a ghee and I'm making the
sounds with the geek you're already in
the point where he's holding the knife
and he's telling you to do [ __ ] how do
you get out of that as a fighter you
know watching that scene I in the first
episode of Dahmer I was like I think you
would have murked me for sure I don't
think I would have gotten out just no
hope I think Nick would have [ __ ] him
so good and he would have passed
and then it would have got out like yeah
I just walked out the front door hey
thanks man yeah next right in my back
yeah I would do that I would do that you
would have just kissed them bro I would
blow his back out so good dude
for survivorship though while you're
using martial arts you have no defense
for that situation [ __ ] dude let me let
me let's let's like if you had it yeah
try it out let's see like see this
wouldn't work bro that's all you got it
you gotta hold your little game yeah
that looks pretty cool I think that's
just kung fu yeah looks pretty tight
honestly yeah yeah I think that and I I
remember looking at that machete and I
was like that's [ __ ] really big
machete dude that's really big but isn't
there ways to disarm a guy from a
machete I don't know you know the best
ways
it's not my wheelhouse dude so I
actually you know seniors fight back I
actually went to that because oh you did
yeah I was helping them out and uh Ron
skulls then he was teaching right and he
was saying like the best thing to do in
situations like that is to just be aware
and to not even be in that situation in
the first place because that's the best
self-defense don't get old don't walk
down the street
no abstinence is the best way
it is don't be a horny guy it literally
is though
that's what all yeah that's true when
you are in that situation and they have
a weapon you want to like grab them
right here and do a clinch a clinch is
that what it's called yeah yeah the guy
has a machine yeah you gotta come in
like this and he's gonna like you know
what I mean yeah but can't try it on Pat
right now
let's work shopping huh
I think you've got to get a stool or a
chair yeah you got to create this and
then yeah just like in Chinese films
where they get the folding chair with
this oh you know what if I had a jacket
I'd take that off dude and I go classic
Jackie and I go hey I don't want trouble
I don't want trouble that's true then I
put my jacket on him just watch that
movie again
it's so [ __ ] good rush hour is such a
good rush hour is a gym class oh my I
gotta watch it again it's so good is it
the fourth in production right now I
don't know is it I believe it I think so
nothing beats one yeah another beats one
oh yeah one's June towel right hey
whatever yeah I don't remember yeah
underrated dude there's a reason we all
remember that guys dude that dude's sick
he needs his own spin-off team yeah that
fool is like cultural you know what I
mean yeah we need we need Jun Tao minute
dude he was ahead of his time and he had
the blonde hair and everything yeah dude
he was [ __ ] Asian Cisco that's what
K-pop is now but that wasn't Juneau
joondal was the white guy the the guy
with the blonde hair the Asian got the
Cisco Asian guy was yeah Cisco Asian guy
was the assistant oh what's that name
but he was unnamed I thought that was
dude that guy was assumed that it was
Juneau you thought he was June 10. he's
the fake June time they picked you out
with a white man spoiler alert sorry
guys
the Star Wars level spoiler alert
if you haven't seen Rush Hour by now
it's like yeah what are you doing dude
yeah don't be an [ __ ] what year did
Rush Hour come out sorry who gives a
[ __ ] right continue back to Donald let's
go seriously would you guys be like more
uh sensitive about uh like the Dahmer
thing resurging if uh he had only killed
Indian guys what if he had only killed
like if that was his Mo to kill straight
Indian comedians straight Indian males
from Jersey who are not doctors
that's interesting I don't know how I
would feel about it think about that
demo all the Indians that didn't become
doctors from Jersey because you know
like a lot of [ __ ] do one of
their main problems is like you know
people in the in the gay black commuter
like dude that's [ __ ] up like she's
killing our people yeah
they were they're upset that they were
killing that he was killing their people
and that I guess those I only watched
episode one yeah does it because that's
all you need to watch really does it
demonstrate yeah does it demonstrate
that the cops didn't give a [ __ ] about
the gay black community that's why it
went on so long there was a black
neighbor who was like for a year this
lady who was like yo it smells like
death yeah she was trying to tell but I
read that that wasn't that was
fictionalized that he wasn't actually a
neighbor she lived in another complex oh
so you made a whole other building over
she smelled death yeah it's death over
there the lady the lady that wrote like
the
like the best-selling uh biography of
the guy said like that wasn't true that
was fictionalized so that they could
enhance the story
the thing is it's like something like
that could happen in real life too like
somebody could be calling the cops and
Dad I don't want to listen to it but
there was an actual phone call though
that the lady was like hey I think
there's something going on here and the
cops was like oh no we already took care
of it but then they did I mean that
sounds about right yeah yeah so I could
see that but there wouldn't be any more
of like a feeling if it was something
closer to you I would think I would
think uh part of me would be like that's
[ __ ] up he's killing all these people
but also like all right cool Indian
people getting their shine finally
hot commodity
it would be dope to have like 9 or 12
Indian actors being played portrayed on
television people he killed and then it
ends with a Bollywood credit scene just
all dancing with the serial killer and
zombies and [ __ ] you [ __ ] fire it'll
set up the finale you know I'm sure I'm
sure there's serial killers in India
that obviously only kill Indian people
and [ __ ] we never hear about them we
likely never will but if we're
glorifying we gotta get some shot on
them for sure I think they need some
they need some publicists man yeah yeah
yeah you guys got to park here so I want
to see the Bollywood serial killer movie
that'd be so is there such a thing no I
don't know no but the Bollywood movies
of this [ __ ] anyways dudes they're
probably looking at serial murders like
that [ __ ] is too basic yeah we need to
be riding in on elephants jumping over
Bridges and exploding atomic bombs that
bring us into space I love Bollywood
scenes so sick just put so much work
into that they're the best like I think
they're aware they're self-aware of how
crazy they are so now now that's not no
longer parody it's like we're just gonna
have fun with it and I think it's
beautiful that's what I'm saying the
Dahmer version Bollywood style like I
want to see that [ __ ] I feel like Vin
Diesel is copying Bollywood you know
what I mean like Indian movies Vin
Diesel and fast Vin Diesel yeah the
whole Furious franchise I feel like
they're just trying to do what Indian
people I've been doing in cinema you
know overactive yeah you know what you
know what I think they're doing I think
they're slowly trying to prep us for
Indian Cinema oh good so they're just
getting more and more bollywood-ish
until we are finally ready to accept how
cool is which it is that's what the
Rock's doing too that's why he's like
that's the next Market I gotta tap into
well you see I see it pushed on like my
Netflix all the time but oh yeah yeah
more about and I'm like oh [ __ ] they're
like Bollywood uh Netflix produced
Bollywood films and I see that on my
Netflix all the time I just don't know
which one to watch oh you want to know
RR that one's hilarious the one that
came out on Netflix [ __ ] action
movies just two buff ass dudes it's
banana are they doing like Superman [ __ ]
because that's what I really like I have
to see this it's Superman stuff there's
like the way they like dramaticize and
set up like Hero characters and stuff
everybody's super scared about this
thing like these this tiger or some [ __ ]
these mobs like jump up on this fence
everybody's like oh they're all scared
except for one dude he's just standing
there all Stern and stuff the way they
set up Heroes later on when he takes off
sure he's got like 14 pack yeah that's
tight yeah whenever someone describes
the body of a movie it sounds like a
child describing something
and then those tires
that's Bollywood exactly I'm like doing
a good job he sure it is honey he sure
it is here eat your vegetables
I will say though that I think Indian
dance films are better than American
dance films Oh by far you've seen one
you seen an Indian dance move anything's
better than step up too in the streets
never see step up two in the Stream but
it's the plot it's like I didn't realize
this because we know like as dancers
were always like why aren't dance movies
so like corny but then you guys haven't
written one oh because because we can
only do the dancing we can't do the
writing what was you do you think you
got served with corny no I thought that
was like I actually thought that was
perfect but uh there's Indian ones where
they mix in cultural things and that's
what I realized it's like in dance films
it can't tap into any like cultural
stuff like in street dancer 3D which is
like a pretty big dance uh movie in
India the plot is that this one dancer
guy who's like traveling gets offered to
to uh kind of bring some like to
illegally bring some other like Indian
guys over to like UK and they get stuck
there and then they were like cheated
out of their like indentured servitude
so they were gonna come to a job and
they actually like got scammed and now
they're like begging him to like help
them and he's like ah man I'm I'm trying
to dance damn that sounds pretty real
it's like you get to see like oh
culturally that's a [ __ ] real problem
but then in dance films there is no real
problem it's just the rec center dance
is a problem dance is a solution it's
okay that's that's what I mean and
that's life baby problem dance the
solution we're setting like a rom-com
setting or some [ __ ] like that right
exactly yeah step up two setting half of
them or it's like fish out of water
setting it's like that kind of deal they
were just dancing in the streets that's
all I remember yeah like Save the Last
Dance and stuff and it gets real when
they talk about like every Indian person
in that film their parents don't want
them to dance so it's pretty [ __ ]
right on them uh I mean I know Hassan is
working Hudson is working on a him as
co-creator working on a dance movie
about like the Indian dance community
and college dances and stuff but it's
odd to me that
in that movie you're talking about that
the Indian parents don't want someone
dance like my parents forced my sister
to dance
as a career well as a career no but as
like a thing to pursue just like in my
system yeah and like my sister my and to
my cousins were like obsessed with it
and is there a separation in like just
the girls though not the guys yeah I
mean Bart not team is classic Indian
Indian dance and it was something that
they made them do and then my sister and
my two other cousins like became like
very involved in because it was
part of their culture became like a very
identifying thing for them that had huge
meats and at the bay obviously didn't go
on like doing it forever but there's
still a huge Indian dance Community like
big competitions and all that so it's
odd to me that people like don't dance I
think it's hard to turn into a career
yeah that's where it's different because
I don't see we didn't see a lot of
Indian dancers in the industry so I saw
Bhangra dancers when I would do shows
and stuff but that was its own industry
I feel like exactly yeah I mean that's
just the Indian entertainment industry
and dance and that culture was so big on
its own yeah that they it was just so
clearly another industry it's huge like
where people that were not Indian would
get hired to participate in those like
that industry sometimes or didn't smack
also do like Indian Dancing Yeah Yeah
she got hired to do a Just Dance India
like Bhangra yeah and that's what the
rotation it was with ritesh yeah ritesh
was the leader dude the movie should be
about that culture uh that whole scene
with with Jeffrey Dahmer like coming in
and only targeting the people that's
like oh you're trying to come up with
your dance queer I'm I'm murdering take
some photos for you his name is Jeffrey
uh what's a what's the Indian last name
Patel Patel
we're over here in Hollywood we're like
how come there's not a lot of Indian
dancers in these uh these music videos
and stuff nowadays all of them keep
getting murdered by Jeffrey
Patel dude name of the show Patel Patel
yeah so I guess it doesn't really matter
like in terms of race it's just a bad
thing that uh it's glorifying a murder
so heinous right if I was like halfway
serial killer let's say I've done like
you know three four murders already and
I'm trying to work up to my Legend and
then I see a Netflix show and it's just
like Dumber right yeah Mama and I'm like
oh my God one day it's gonna be Lee you
know what I'm saying I'm like it's fully
glorifying yeah you're giving them an
Olympics basically yeah it's also a
thing for a lot of those guys like they
are narcissists and that's what they're
seeking you know they're seeking fame
even though it's through that Avenue so
yeah and he puts like you said any
potential guy or like School shooters
that's why there's copycats it's the
same [ __ ] it's like because they're
being glorified you know what though
there's another point and Jason Cheney
said it yesterday you know Jason Cheney
I don't know who that is anyway you guys
saw each other's penises but we'll talk
about it later talk about that later but
he was saying like especially about
Jeffrey Dahmer he goes yeah like all
these guys probably want their name out
there and all that but at the end of the
day they just want to be loved too like
everyone else
that's what Jason Jenny said damn that's
empathy bro that's empathetic you know I
mean but Jason Cheney's like oh that's
so nice that's true though because his
dad [ __ ] never loved him man you saw
that Jeffrey Dahmer's dead yeah Jeffrey
I think you're talking about Jason I was
like damn dude
Jason your father never loved you man
that's that's a Star Wars spoiler that's
why he goes around showing his dick to
other dudes yeah Pat can confirm his bad
dad really didn't love him he tells me
all the time he's like my dad didn't
love me and then I hug him and then he
pulls out his dick and that's usually
that's our friendship that's how it
happens you know what you want to know
the worst [ __ ] movie out of all the
things all the elements we've discussed
a Bollywood film
that's an Indian version of Expendables
where all the characters are past School
shooters High School shooters what thank
you guys for joining us
[Music]